President Trump is spending another day
trying to both advocate for stricter gun
laws and to clarify his positions on one
of the most divisive subjects for both
his supporters and critics not far from
the White House conservatives are being
warned by the head of the gun lobby that
gun rights opponents are using the floor
to school massacre to go after their
weapons chief White House correspondent
John Rother starts us off tonight with
another day looking for answers good
evening John break it evening to you was
the second media that President Trump
convened here at the White House on the
Marjory Stoneman Douglas school shooting
meeting with state and local officials
today to hear suggestions and float a
few ideas of his own how we can make our
school safe resident Trump build these
White House meetings as listening
sessions but on one issue the president
did far more talking than listening we
have to harden our schools not soften
them up a gun-free zone to a killer or
somebody that wants to be a killer
that's like going in for the ice cream
that's like Here I am take me calling
gun-free zones nonsense
president Trump pressed hard his idea to
train and arm qualified teachers or
school staff to stand as the frontline
against a school shooter so practically
for free you have now made the school
into a hardened target I think we need
hardened sites we need to let people
know you come into our schools you're
gonna be dead and it's gonna be fast and
unless you do that you can always have
this problem while a handful of schools
have already adopted the idea getting
the sort of widespread buy-in necessary
to serve as a national deterrent will be
a challenge for the White House so far
much of the reaction that we've seen to
this idea has been negative
does the president expect that he can
get enough by in order to send a signal
potential shooters out there that this
is a hardened facility you walk in the
doors he said a little while ago you're
not going to last but you certainly
think so look there are a lot of
individuals leaders in Congress you know
the NRA has been supportive of this idea
a lot of other folks have been
supportive of this idea president Trump
insists his plan could put an end to
school shootings but it wasn't his only
idea tweeting this morning I will be
strongly pushing comprehensive
background checks with an emphasis on
mental health raise age to 21 and in
sale of bump stocks raising the age to
buy a rifle or shotgun puts President
Trump at odds with the NRA which
fiercely opposes changes in a statement
saying passing a law that makes it
illegal for a 20 year old to purchase a
shotgun for hunting or an adult single
mother from purchasing the most
effective self-defense rifle on the
market punishes law-abiding citizens for
the evil acts of criminals and while the
NRA says there's been no change in its
position President Trump believes they
will work it out the NRA wants to do the
right thing I've spoken to him often in
the last two days and they want to do
the right thing they're gonna do the
right thing I have no doubt about it
the Douglas high school shooting has
ignited passions in the political arena
at a CNN Town Hall last night Florida
Republican Senator Marco Rubio was
confronted by the father of a young
woman killed at Douglas your comments
this week and those of our president had
been pathetically weak on Capitol Hill a
group of Democrats said a letter to
speaker Paul Ryan asking him to allow
debate to repeal an NRA backed amendment
from 1996 that prohibits the CDC from
doing research into gun violence and the
FBI also weighed in today the acting
deputy director responding to why the
FBI failed to act on a January tip about
the Douglass school shooter there now
let me be clear there was a mistake made
we know that but it is our job to make
sure that we do everything in our power
to ensure that does not happen again I'm
not making excuses because what happened
was a tragedy truly a tragedy President
Trump also suggested a changing the
language around active shooter drills at
school saying that they should simply be
called safety drills because young
students participating in an active
shooter drill could be trauma to
traumatized simply by the language right
John Roberts live in the North Lawn John
thanks